[Applause]
[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
we are delighted that our guest today is
the founder
of colette claire lehman welcome to
trigonometry
hi guys thanks so much for having me oh
it's an absolute pleasure this interview
has been a while in the making we've
been trying to make it happen we're so
excited
the time difference is crazy it's monday
morning as we're recording this where
you are it's sunday very late at night
here
uh so uh you're just having your coffee
we've had to have some coffee to stay
awake
so it's all good uh but so much to talk
about
um listen one of the things that we we
were really interested to to discuss
with you is
you talked in some of your previous
interviews about the fact that
at quillet which is a fantastic
publication i've written for a number of
times myself
you don't do the kind of this is what
happened today here's a news story about
that
rather you take a step back and you look
at some of the trends some of the
the big things that are happening the
big ideas the big debates and so on
so as you as we sit here in the middle
of august
2020 what are some of the big things
that you see
as having happened and potentially
looking forward what is it that
that you kind of are thinking about at
the moment
well that's an interesting question uh i
would say
that uh all of the big trends
that i was thinking about prior to
covert 19
all of a sudden accelerating they're
speeding up
so there was a brief point in time
when the pandemic had just started where
i thought that the culture wars
would simmer down and
we'd get over identity politics because
people would realize that there's more
important things to worry about
such as you know biomedical health
technology
you know uh like real things in the real
world such as viruses
um but it seems like because everybody's
been
locked down and lot cooped up in their
homes and they've been spending all of
this time on the internet
but suddenly the culture wars have
accelerated
and intensified much greater than what
i would have ever expected so all of the
culture war
trends that i was thinking about prior
to 2020
uh i'm now thinking about them again
because they're intensifying and then
the other
patterns or trends that i find
interesting at the moment are the
economic ones so the speeding up
of the shift from uh
businesses being sort of like brick and
mortar shops on the street to being
online businesses
and how that's going to affect society
and how that's going to affect
politics long term
and clear were you surprised at the way
the coronavirus has affected the culture
wars because i was very much in
agreement with you i thought
this is the time humanity is going to
pull together we're all going to hold
hands
well gloves but you know we're going to
hold gloves we're all going to be in
peaceful with one another
and it just seems that everybody
collectively
lost their minds well i
i i saw some good uh
there were some good signs in australia
so i live in sydney australia and
at the start of the pandemic i felt like
everybody
um was you know
there was a sense of solidarity so we
live in a australia is a fairly high
trust society we're multicultural but
everyone seems to get along with each
other fairly well
and we didn't have the kind of the
immediate bickering
over you know lockdowns and that kind of
thing we had a lockdown but everyone
seemed to
you know um comply so we didn't have
this immediate bickering that happened
maybe in the united states or even in
the uk
um and we don't have like we all went
when we're on the train we all wear
masks and the mask is not like a
a culture war um
sort of symbol like it is in america uh
so in australia it's a little bit
different but i think as the pandemic
keeps going on and people get fatigued
fatigued and worn out
particularly with lockdowns and that
kind of thing um
there'll be more bickering but what i've
noticed is that
the stress and the strain of the
pandemic has really
brought to brought any kind of tensions
or fractures within a country
out so obviously in america everything
all of their divisions are much more
noticeable now
i don't know exactly what's happening in
the uk but
i think in nations that are doing well
are fairly are the ones that have
maintained their level of trust so
australia japan
um new zealand potentially
well it's interesting you talk about the
uk i mean actually you know
we talk about the solidarity we did have
a little bit of that at the beginning i
thought for the first month or two that
was happening
and i think what then happened is and i
i know you've talked about this in the
past as well in terms of importing stuff
uh from the united states what then
happened is suddenly we had
having gone from like you know if you're
outside sunbathing
uh your criminal and your your killings
everyone around you
to the next week uh massive riots in the
streets no one's socially distancing
and nobody's saying a word about that
you know
yeah the black lives matter protest is
that what you're referring to
yes yeah we had one in melbourne
quite a big one and one in sydney where
i am and
uh but i was actually really impressed
with our
health officials and they came out and
said don't go
and the prime minister and other
elected members of parliament said this
is ridiculous this is an american issue
this is not australia
and don't go on protest so i was
actually really impressed
by the the courage well it
didn't even require courage it's just
the common sense of our politicians
and saying that don't go on protest
during a pandemic
sounds pretty racist to me
but you know you know we bring up this
idea of uh
importing the culture war how much do
you think that's true because
so many of these issues i mean us in the
uk over in your country in australia
they just don't map onto what we've got
in our countries
at all and yet we're all having this
conversation as if this is like
the united states yeah oh it's a
it's a concerning um
trent it's just i think it's because the
united states is the
world's global superpower at the moment
and we
obviously you know we all speak the same
language
and we import so much of their cultural
products from music
to entertainment um and it's just an
unfortunate side effect that we have to
import their
culture war issues as well but funnily
enough
you know we've never imported their um
evangelical kind of christian cultures
like we don't have
you know uh we don't have much division
in australia over
abortion um we don't have
you know uh protests about gun rights we
have gun
control here so i mean on the one hand
we get things like black lives matter
being imported here but on the other
hand we ne
they never really take root because we
have
we've already dealt with many of the
issues that the united states has not
yet dealt with
so is that in some ways is that the
solution to
the the kind of exporting of the culture
war is to get your society sorted out
so you're not that vulnerable to all
this crazy stuff
well i mean every nation has its own
history obviously and
and a culture is intertwined with the
nation's history and it's not so simple
as just
giving everyone you know access to free
health care or like university it's not
that simple so like if you take
an issue like gun rights in america i
mean that is intertwined with
their nation's founding so it's just
it's not you can't compare
the gun rights issue in the united
states to australia
because they're so deeply fundamental to
that
society's cultural beliefs and value
system that we just
we can't really understand it so i mean
it's yeah it is concerning that we have
to deal with this identity politics
which is largely an
america an american phenomenon being
imported into australia but
i'm optimistic and confident that our
society will never
really go down the same path to being
so divided over identity as the united
states i mean
it could that could me be me being too
hopeful but
we'll see and do you think part of the
reason i think it is being too helpful
i'm gonna be honest with you yeah i i
i thought there was exactly the same
thing in the uk though like it's gone
pretty crazy
yeah really and oh yeah it's gone tom
type it really really has but one of the
questions
i wanted to ask is how much of a
responsibility do you think
social media should bear the brunt for
it for this because
in times gone by we would never have
heard of these cases or if they
would do it'd only be a footnote in a
newspaper
but now it just seems to be spread at
the touch of the bottom like a virus
right around the globe in a matter of
seconds yeah
well any kind of uh revolutionary
technology is going to have
disruptive impacts on society and i
the way i think of social media and the
internet more generally is that it's the
equivalent to the printing press um and
so the printing press
when it when it was invented it
um brought about the reformation and
then hundreds of years
of religious warring but at the same
time we i mean those things obviously
bad but we wouldn't say to ourselves we
don't want to live in a world where the
printing press was not invented
so i see the internet as being as being
a double-edged
sword it's going to make
uh it's going to bring about a lot of
progress
and in terms of technology and bringing
very creative
smart people together at the same time
it's going to disrupt our societies
and our political systems to the point
where there may even be trauma and
bloodshed
but in a hundred or two hundred years
time would we turn around and say oh we
wish the internet was never invented i
don't think so
and i think the same goes for social
media if you think about the world's
most brilliant most creative individuals
linking them up via social media or
or by any kind of mechanism i mean
that has the potential to unleash so
much creativity
that can benefit humanity in the long
term that i think it's worth it
i don't know and then you go on twitter
and you think really
well i was thinking i mean twitter is
the exact opposite of that isn't it
twitter is linking up all the most
mentally unstable
diluted in one big web
isn't it yeah yes it is but i like to
think of
long term about the long term i mean
what
what if the people who are working on a
coronavirus vaccine are linked
up via uh you know
not twitter but what if the what if the
information gets
shared much more rapidly than it ever
could before
and it means that we can defeat this
pandemic you know
so i just i think with any technological
advancement we have to be careful not to
throw the baby out with the bath water
and um you know colette itself is an
internet phenomenon i could never have
established
an online magazine without twitter
because that's where i met my writers
and that's where we distribute
our articles for free uh like i'm not
i don't have hundreds of millions of
dollars to like send
hard copies of my magazine around to all
of the cities in the world
but because of the internet and because
of twitter you know people in
all parts of the world students can log
on
for free read quillette for free and get
what i think is you know some
pretty good quality content so you know
we've gotta we've gotta have a balanced
view i think
absolutely on the one hand you've got
200 years of religious warfare another
one you've got quillette
there you go sorry francis go ahead nate
no um but quillette has been such a
huge success and right right from its
inception this growth has been
phenomenal
why do you think that is uh well
i mean one of the reasons is why
one of the reasons why is because we
have been dealing with
i mean we've been talking about what we
now call cancer culture
we've been talking about that trend
since we started so that was back in
2015
so i mean now cancer culture has sort of
entered into the mainstream lexicon and
there's articles about it in
mainstream newspapers and magazines you
know people are discussing
how bad it really is and whether it's
really a thing well we were talking
about these things
five years ago and so um
i think we've just been ahead of the
curve in in identifying
some of the pathologies of identity
politics
and censorship and the group think
that's
plaguing institutions such as media
academia
and maybe the arts so i think we've just
been
we were sort of the first movies on that
um
and then the other the other reason for
our success is
you know we're not limited by space
because publishing on a digital platform
doesn't really cost much at all we can
publish quite
lengthy essays where people take a deep
dive into issues sometimes technical
issues
with that without us saying oh you've
got to cut you know you've got to um
you know cut it down because if you're
publishing a newspaper you often
are very limited in your space like
columnists may only get 600 words
everything has to be condensed down and
sometimes that means
it's dumbed down because we are
we don't have those limitations we allow
people more freedom
writers more freedom to explore ideas
and i mean it's not
we don't have our success isn't like
maths we're not successful in a mass
media kind of way but we have a niche so
we're successful in our niche
and that we're lucky that that niche is
big enough around the world to sustain
us
and don't you think that is essentially
now the future of the internet whereas
before
where you know if you thought about
major artists
they had broad appeal you know if you
thought about major publications again
they had broad appeal but very much now
with the rise of the internet it's about
identifying a niche and then serving it
which is what you've done beautifully
yeah yes i think i think that's correct
and uh it i mean it might not mean that
people become household names like they
did
prior to the internet like um madonna
and michael jackson like
we're not going to have that level of
fame and stardom anymore
however um we can lots of people can
enjoy
um sustainable incomes
uh just by finding an audience that
likes them
and they have shared values with and
they connect with
and that and it's very it's a very
fulfilling career to have that
have a niche audience who you can trust
and they trust you and they provide you
with an income
and you serve their them i mean it's
it's very
rewarding and fulfilling and then you
don't have all of the downsides that
come with
you know being super famous like people
did in the
and past don't don't you think as well
that you know the success of quillet and
let's be fair you know the success of
this sharon rogan
doesn't it also highlight the failures
of mainstream media
in that people are no longer want to
engage with it they don't see it as
being trustworthy
they've seen it as being manipulative
and so on and so forth
yeah and i think there's a general move
away from
very slick highly produced
content that people feel is inauthentic
and so you know when i was growing up
when i was a kid
anything that i saw on tv was very
highly produced very slick
sort of scripted know this basically
you know people we're human beings and
we crave connection
and connect with other people
if they're being themselves if they're
being authentic so i think
i think there's a real
audiences around the world are training
towards more
authentic intimate locally
you know you can even see it with food
like you'll go to a cafe
and they'll have science locally grown
organic like there's this
there's a turn away from big mass
produced um you know
homogenized products towards a niche
local intimate authentic and that's
reflected in media
just as anything else is just you know
just like it is in the food industry or
any other industry
hi guys and welcome to my brand new gaff
some of you will have noticed
it looks incredibly different that's
right palacio del pacioni
is no more i got evicted last week so
i'm crashing on my friend's floor
or as it's otherwise known florio
erotico
now we're very excited to have a brand
new sponsor it's expressvpn
that's right expressvpn catchy name
i know now some of you at the back are
wondering what is expressvpn all about
have you ever been on the internet and
looking at things that you don't want
people to be knowing about
we all know what i'm talking about don't
we yes that's right
trigonometry you don't want people
knowing that you're watching and
listening to this show
and you don't want people to find out
about it understandably
that's where expressvpn come in now
there'll be some people
probably the gentleman who'll be
thinking to themselves hang on mate why
don't i just use incognito mode
well let me tell you something your
internet service provider
can still track and find every single
website that you use
even when you're doing it with incognito
mode
that's why whenever i watch this show
i always make sure to use expressvpn
it doesn't matter if you get your
internet from verizon
comcast skype whoever it may be
internet service providers are allowed
to sell your browsing history to other
companies
expressvpn is an app that re-routes
your internet through their secure
servers
so that your internet service provider
can't see
all the problematic interview shows that
you were watching
i'll be honest with you most of the time
i didn't even realize i had
expressvpn on it runs seamlessly
in the background you won't even notice
it all you need to do is give it a tap
and off it goes all you have to do to
get this amazing offer
is use my exclusive link expressvpn.com
trigger and you'll get an extra three
months free
on a one-year package that's right an
extra three months free on a one-year
package
that is 15 months
that e x p r e
s s v p n dot com
slash trigger you see teaching kids how
to spell for 12 years came in useful one
day
and at what point because you have a
range of thinkers on you know you know
and you're not like some people say like
they say the same things about us your
right wing your bubba and you ask them
to explain what right wing is it's
essentially a euphemism for hateful and
racist but there we go
but accurate in our case but um is there
ever a point
where you go right these ideas are
simply
too much or they push too far a
particular thing
like i think you and maybe i'm gonna
misquote you here please correct me if
i'm wrong you said that you wouldn't
put for example minor yiannopoulos on
and have him right
for you at what point do you make that
decision where you go
i'm not interested in someone's
viewpoint yeah
so i'm not really interested in
provocation just for provocation sake uh
we we we're not we're not performance
artists
so we you know the issues that we
explore on colette are pretty serious
issues
and um you know we're not
we're not just into owning the libs or
getting
a reaction out of people and
constantine's base
sorry i
it's not about politics it's just about
basic
human um standards for behavior so i
don't
we don't really uh we very rarely
publish what you would describe as a hit
piece
i mean we have published some articles
that uh
bring up shoddy journalism or like
correct the record
and that sometimes might involve taking
a deep dive into an
into a journalist's work or a writer's
work but we don't
engage in in the kind of nasty ad
hominem attack which is has
unfortunately become
you know a mainstay of mainstream media
for some reason
well just coming back to the mainstream
media claire because france has kind of
touched on it and you were talking about
the fact that people
like locally sourced authentic etc
do you do you also think there's a big
part of it which is less technological
and more
sort of ideological where increasingly i
i can certainly speak for our country
there's increasing perception
actually from both sides of the
political spectrum that the institutions
that
we used to take as being these sort of
neutral arbiters of the truth
are no longer fulfilling that function
at all we see a big
defund the bbc movement in this country
um
there is a feeling among many many
people that the mainstream media
essentially are no longer doing their
job do you think that's also been
a part of it or do you think that's
exaggerated no i think that's definitely
a part of it
and it's so there's technological forces
that are influencing the media but
they i think you're correct it's right
you're right when you say that they have
we when you imply that they have uh
neglected some of their traditional
roles
um i it's hard to it's hard to determine
what exactly has caused this whether
it's
the fact that um the talent that used to
the talent that used to go into
journalism no longer goes into
journalism and you know this
the smartest kids are now doing
something else other than journalism or
whether
um there's just been a lack of
leadership in institutions themselves
it's really hard to pinpoint
what the causal factors are but do you
not think it's small
the kind of long march to the
institutions where over the last
30 to 40 years universities been
increasingly
turning out people with a particular
mindset those people then go into these
professions which attract
mostly university graduates you know we
had a journalist on the show some time
ago mike graham he was talking about the
fact
you know he's probably in his 50s when
he was
coming up through journalism lots of
people considered it more of a kind of
traditional profession as opposed to
something he went into through the
academic group
do you think maybe the transformation of
academia which is something you've
talked about quite a lot has been a big
factor in that
yeah certainly would be a factor i don't
know how big
but it's right um
you're right in that if you're getting a
a big chunk of people within a
profession
who all think the same they're not going
to
notice each other's blind spots so if
you've got a big
chunk of journalists who think that
journalism
is basically the same as activism or
that activism
somehow has a role to play in journalism
which i don't think it does
uh they're not gonna pick up on each
other's blind spots and they're not
gonna
test each other's assumptions test each
other
test each other's work i mean one of the
biggest reasons for intellectual
diversity or viewpoint diversity is not
because
you know conservatives or libertarians
just it's nice to have them included
is to um make sure
good rigorous robust work is done
because when you have people who have
different viewpoints or different
ideological perspectives they
picky pick each other's work apart
and find the flaws in it and that
creates better work
over the long term but if everyone's
thinking the same
you get people get lazy and sloppy
and they're not uh having their their
work thoroughly vetted
by their peers the way it should be so i
think that
part partly the reason why we've seen a
decline
in standards in journalism and you said
yourself
claire that activism can't be part of
journalism
i mean there are plenty of people at the
guardian who would disagree with you
uh why do you say that also plenty of
people are breitbart just to be fair as
well yeah right absolutely
yeah good people on both sides
[Laughter]
that's a reference that shouldn't offend
anyone well done
it's not that journalists shouldn't have
strong convictions or can't have their
own political biases and that kind of
thing but when it comes to the actual
work
i mean journalism is an empirical
profession and it's about finding the
truth
and so that virtue finding the truth
and documenting empirical facts has to
come before everything else so
i think it's fine if a journalist you
know puts truth up here and their
their political biases down here fine
with me
that's pretty much what we do at colette
anyway but it when it that reverses
when the political when a journalist
political goals
are more important to them than finding
the truth
that's a problem and because that then
it's no longer journalism
but don't you think claire we've reached
this stage where practically
every publication now is advocacy
journalism
it's almost impossible to find a
publication which
actually is is objective anymore yeah
i think it's hard to find um
publications according to mars head
alone but i think
that if we look hard enough we'll find
that there still are
journalists with integrity uh but
they're individual so it's it's hard to
pinpoint
a a particular publication
as a whole um but there will be many
individuals working within newspapers
who are still
who still can um who still subscribe
to the more traditional uh understanding
of what journalism is
well except some of them are now leaving
the very institutions which
they've they've been in the barry
weiss's the andrew sullivan's the
uh a lot of people are who who you would
hope
would be the kind of center and the core
of their institutions are actually
feeling like they can't
exist in those spaces anymore which
again i suppose explains the success
of of publications like colette um but
do you think that
we might have entered a slightly
different age although i think you
quillet is a counter example to what i'm
about to say but certainly on on youtube
people who do what we do which
essentially like we say well i say i'm a
centrist francis is
old-school lefty we tell people what we
think we tell people where we're coming
from
and then we have a conversation from
that space
uh that some that's that seems to be
like a totally different shift where
essentially
we're not pretending to be unbiased
right uh whereas the problem with a lot
of the mainstream stuff is they're
saying well this is just the objective
reality we've got no bias at all
here's a story about how you know
dancing is racist or something you know
like
yeah do you think that's that's part of
the shift as well is now
we're kind of looking for people to go
this is who i am this is where i'm
coming from
and here's what i think because of that
yeah i think that's a valid point but
i mean you guys are having conversations
and a lot of the stuff that i publish on
collette
is uh opinion and
when you're expressing your opinion it
helps to have some self-awareness
and it helps to be up front about your
political biases
but what i'm talking about in terms of
putting the truth first talking about if
you're a reporter and you're going out
and observing an event like a
protest if you come back and write it
write a story about how it was
mostly peaceful because only 24 cops got
assaulted you know that's when you
that's when things are getting the lines
are getting a bit blurred between
activism and bias
and reporting on what actually happened
and it's just my view that if your
job is that you're a reporter you have
to report the facts
clearly and uh you know you should try
and minimize bias as much as possible
it's the same with science i mean
if scientists are allowed to have their
political biases that's fine
but if they let the those biases
impact the results that they find from
an experiment
then the whole process is corrupted and
then we no longer have
trust in the scientific enterprise and
then and that's incredibly
damaging long term but isn't part of the
problem as well that you know you may
want to you may go into these
institutions and you may want to be
objective and you may want to
report on the facts but ultimately if
the hierarchy
and the people above you aren't
interested in that then
you're gonna you're doomed to failure
aren't you yeah i mean
of course incentives matter and uh
you know like i i think i mentioned
before
potentially in some of these
institutions the leadership is culpable
the leadership has really been strong
enough to withstand some of these
corrosive forces
uh yeah i think it would be tremendously
difficult for any junior
journalist in the abc or the bbc or
wherever
who has a more traditional view of
journalism going in and having to
navigate
all of the internal politics of these
organizations
particularly when leadership might be
very biased or
have a different understanding of what
journalism journalism is
all right well we've bashed the evil msm
enough i feel for for one episode
um look one of the fascinating things
about colette is you get a lot of people
from the scientific world
to write about uh a lot of the things
that
have become invariably part of the
culture war
you know gender differences between men
and women uh
you know iq research all that sort of
stuff so
what what have been and what will be
some of the most important
kind of scientific things that quillet
has covered and will cover
uh in relation to you know some of those
those things like
uh the stuff that we talk about on the
show
well i think it's certainly our coverage
of sex differences
has been uh quite influential i think
um we were the first publication to
really
uh commission and solicit
articles and commentary from uh
evolutionary psychologists and even
neuroscientists who are ex like world
leading experts in this area
and i i've seen
articles that look you know quite
similar to our own articles
end up on place at places like the
atlantic so i think
we've been a leader in that area i think
intelligence research is certainly um
we've you know we've certainly
contributed to that
uh to more understanding perhaps
among intellectuals about intelligence
research but it's still such a taboo
scientific area i
i don't see that uh the science in that
area becoming mainstream anytime soon
or or understood at a mainstream level i
think
i think sex differences is used to be
quite taboo
and it would scientists have had to be
really brave to even discuss it without
uh because they they feared being called
sexist
but i think that's broken down over the
last five or ten years
and um and now people can discuss sex
differences uh quite openly perhaps not
at google
but i think and other places people can
talk about them
i think it'll take a bit longer for
intelligence research it's still
really taboo and people are still really
uncomfortable talking about it so
um it's interesting that you say that
because i didn't realize
you know you said i i intelligence
research is a taboo subject and i
assumed you were talking about
the the race and iq so are you saying
that like
research which finds that different
people have different iqs and that's
somehow related to their genetics
is that taboo uh i would say that the
any research that finds that there is a
genetic component
to intelligence is taboo but there any
isn't that a statement of the bleeding
obvious though that
we you know we have a lot of outside of
academia
so people outside of academia have a lot
more sense about this than
than within academia in a way academia
it's it's very tricky to argue that any
any form of human behavior i mean we
know
that uh 50 of psychological traits
are heritable we know that from 30 years
of
behavioral genetic studies but you won't
find very many academics willing to say
that publicly
particularly in psychology it's fraught
it's absolutely fraught particularly
around socially valued traits such as
intelligence
and why is this i mean because you know
i'm a former teacher everybody can now
drink sorry that's
that's a game we play constant mention
is russian i'm a former teacher
but you could see that you know if if if
a child had bright parents or parents
you know who had you know good jobs or
whatever else
they were more likely to be academically
capable that just seems obvious in that
if you have two parents who are sporty
the kid's probably going to be sporty
etc etc etc why is a common sense
idea which everybody accepts in the real
world why is that taboo in academia
well i mean people have been trying to
understand that for a long time now this
is famous book by stephen pinker called
the blank slate that was written back in
2002 and he tried to explore all of the
reasons why
we find it hard or that or not everybody
but the intellectual class of society
why we find it so difficult to deal with
human nature and the heritable nature of
human
nature sorry that's a a mouthful but
and there are there are various reasons
but a big one is simply that
um there are narratives
or assumptions particularly within
progressive
political ideology that frown upon
acknowledging
that we are born with a human nature
because
it's seen as being uh incompatible
with and this notion that if you
create beautiful environments for
everyone
people can flourish naturally so i think
i think it's seen as an
impediment to um good politics basically
so if you
if you acknowledge that some kids will
always struggle in school
then um i think there's this fear that
suddenly you won't pour money into
schools or something like that i mean
there's a you have to take a few steps
to try and understand
where this fear comes from but
it's it's been a huge part of our
culture for some time now that we
haven't been able to honestly deal with
the fact that people differ individually
and as groups
and uh you know i think some of the
culture wars
uh issues are they're a result of that
and do you think claire as well it's you
know and you have children
and you know we give children this
narrative that you can be anything you
want you can do anything you want
all you need to do is put your head down
work hard enough and the world is your
oyster
when the reality is when we're talking
about iq is
there's some children unfortunately
you're never going to be capable of
being a doctor or you know being being a
scientist they're simply
not intelligent enough and that is
brutal and heartbreaking
and if you say to these people right at
the start that
because of your iq you're simply never
going to achieve this isn't
isn't that an awful message to send to
people
however accurate it might be well you
know i'm never going to be
uh i'm never going to win the 100 meters
sprint
you know racing you're right that's why
[Laughter]
there's lots of things that we can't all
do
i think one thing that we've lost
however is this notion that all human
beings
are have the same moral worth and same
inherent dignity and i think
intelligence is a really
thorny and tricky subject because we so
often
uh mistake uh we so often confuse
intelligence with human worth and that's
really bad
i mean we should be able to separate um
the a person's ability to perform in our
modern economy from their inherent worth
you know a person can be
kind funny warm loving
caring without being particularly bright
you know and we shouldn't judge you know
we we tied we put too much emphasis and
value on intelligence
rather than those other qualities such
as kindness and funniness and
you know and and then and uh
bravery those types of human qualities
that i think we used to value more in
our society but
we've sort of lost well actually i think
it goes deeper than that perhaps claire
as well which
which is that rather than looking at an
alternative source of value
we might want to look at one of the
breakthroughs of western civilization is
that everybody has value irrespective
everybody is valuable irrespective of
their qualities or values in other words
the three of us have different
intelligence we have different
attractiveness we have different this
and that and and maybe
one of us is morally good and one of us
isn't right point of myself as i said of
course
but but but nonetheless we're all human
beings and that means
we have moral value and we have
inalienable inalienable rights that are
protected
by the state from others that that was
actually quite a revolutionary idea when
when it became part of our civilization
um and and that fear of of
seeing that people are different it
reminds me and i know you've talked
about this as well as how
you first encountered the sort of uh
almost black listing by australian media
when you wanted to be critical of
aspects of feminism
and it seems to me like that issue is
very strong with liberal feminism where
it's like we have to pretend that men
and women are the same because if
they're not
we can't achieve equality which seems
like a crazy idea
yeah yeah i yeah that's right there's
this
uh notion that if you're different you
are not equal
and it's confu there's a confusion
between moral equality and
empirical inequality uh now we're never
gonna be equal
empirically we're never gonna be i'm
never gonna be able to run the hundred
meters as fast as
usain bolt uh but
that doesn't mean i should i shouldn't
be considered
equally human and have equal human worth
um so we you know we we
our culture seems to have lost this
understanding that equality is meant to
be a moral
aim and a moral goal it's about equal
human worth and dignity
uh and we're focusing way too much on
empirical
equality and i don't really know how to
wind that back
or get the conversation back on track to
moral equality
but it's something that we have to do if
we're going to make any progress in
these really thorny topics and the thing
is these thorny topics
are essential uh for resolving some of
these cultural
issues i mean some of the arguments that
people are having
are completely divorced from facts and
from
empirical reality so we we really need
to talk about
what we know as empirical facts before
we can
solve any of these political issues so
we need to have these honest
conversations
and claire do you think part of the
problem is as well like you said that we
don't fight we don't value
you know honesty kindness bravery and
you know i agree with you but that we
don't
this isn't part of the problem and i'm
going to say this with my left wing
head-on is that
you can't monetize that yeah and because
you can't monetize it
it's therefore not seen as a value
whereas you know if you're great at put
you know programming or coding
you know or any of these things that
come with having a high iq
you can monetize it make a lot of money
and therefore you have value
yeah absolutely and that's something i
wish we could talk about more
i mean women for example on average are
more empathetic and more highly
agreeable right but you can't scale
those qualities you can't scale up
empathy
like you can uh being a fantastic coder
like if you
if you look at tech billionaires i mean
they've
some of them have just invented a
snippet of code and
and but that has allowed them to you
know monet
you know that their the ability of them
to monetize that is just astronomical
you can't monetize you know if you're a
extremely caring nurse who heals people
in the hospital
if you're an amazing nanny who looks
after people's children
you can't scale that up but the work
that you do
as a human being and even the work that
you do within the modern economy is so
important and so vital and so beneficial
to other people
that we could not go without it but it's
not
scalable and so i wish we talked about
that more
because it i do think certain skill sets
are
incredibly valuable and fundamental to
our species
but they're not valued enough or they're
undervalued simply because they're not
as monetizable and when you say that we
should talk about it more do you feel
like there's a solution that's there
to to change that somehow
well i mean one way to compensate
people for having a skill set or doing
work which is not
doesn't you know make them rich is just
by
affording them prestige you know so if
we
if if um if you know carers of elderly
people in aged care homes were
afforded more prestige like i'm sure
that they would feel better
about the important work that they they
do you know i just think
that just because something uh
can is easily monetizable or can make a
great deal of money
um you know that has rewards in itself
but there are other ways to compensate
people for the work that they do
particularly if it's very important
vital work to our society
those things i mean it's very very
interesting that you say that that we
should be you know that we should bring
prestige
it's do you sometimes think as well it's
it's just
the incentives that are wrong in our
society
and because you know if you have a high
iq you naturally think to yourself right
well
what is ultimately going to make me
successful is it going to be
being more empathetic being more kind
being more caring or is it actually
going to mean that i'm going to be more
hyper focused i'm going to be more
you know driven all the rest of it that
is going to take me to where i need to
be
yeah well i mean i hesitate to say that
the incentives in our society are wrong
but i think we can do a better job
at um
at providing people with other
rewards rather than just economic
and and there needs to be more of a uh
awareness that i mean
you know people do jobs not necessarily
because of the money
people do jobs because they find it
fulfilling and rewarding and that sort
of thing
you know there are other there are lots
of ways to make a lot of money but
they're not necessarily good for the
soul
but i think if we're talking about you
bankers
um i think if we were just you know if
the if
the conversation was just broader and
some of these issues
were um you know we talked
about them a bit more freely and
honestly that would be that would be
better but i mean
i don't i don't think everyone just
calculates how much money they can earn
just you know through a particular job
and
and and only chooses that job i think we
we choose the job that we do for a range
of different reasons and i think most
people intuitively understand that
i guess what you're talking about is a
little bit like uh having a high regard
for
people in armed services which used to
be much more the case than it is now
like you know not necessarily well paid
but
held in very high esteem in many
societies so i suppose
uh re-routing that to you know as you
talk about doctors and nurses and so on
or having more of that um yeah i
that's an interesting conversation i
just i i wonder how you
how you engineer that socially um what
do you think
i don't think you can i i don't think we
you can
from a top-down point of view you can't
you can't you can't organize that by
fear
it has to come from the grassroots and
it has to come organically but i think
we used to do a better job particularly
for women
i think for example mothers were more
highly regarded
generations ago and uh you know it's sad
that that
i i just think it's sad that some of
that has been lost
and clear you know we talk about
intelligence and we had noah carl on the
show
and noah was saying that there's really
and maybe i'm misquoting him
i'm i hope not but essentially there's
only one real type of intelligence
whereas when i was in teacher training
college they said there were multiple
types of intelligence there was also
emotional intelligence etc etc
we all know that person who could ace
maths exams and then when it comes to a
human connection interaction they'd fall
apart where do you stand on this
well i mean i from so i study psychology
at university and
um i would have learned the same things
that noah has
learned although his education is
probably more recent than mine
but yeah i think there's only one type
of general intelligence
but i would qualify that in saying
that uh the person can have
there are different cognitive profiles
so
uh some particularly when it comes to
people on the
right hand side of the bell curve so if
you're getting into the gifted areas
people can be gifted in very different
ways
and i think jordan peterson has spoken
about this as well so
if you if you if you suspect a child or
an adult is
gifted they might be gifted in just one
area
and then have average abilities in other
areas
uh or they might have just very uh spiky
profiles i think this turns up in people
who have asperger's they have
what's called a spiky profile so they're
very they have high scores
maybe on arithmetic or some other you
know subset
of um an intelligent scale and then
lower scores on others so
i think uh i mean
so i so i think both views are right
it's it's not correct to say there are
different types of intelligence
but simply that when we test people
people can have uh different
cognitive profiles and particularly when
we're getting into the gifted areas
people can have very
divergent kind of results um
and that's it's not unusual but one when
we're getting into the left-hand side of
the bell curve when people are
struggling
with an intelligence test the profiles
are
more similar so that i mean that i don't
i don't know the reason for that but
that's that's uh
i think that's a general finding and do
not worry that
i mean that these sort of tests could be
misused you know like companies or
whatever else or
you know if you want to move to another
country they'll say right if anything
below like a one two eight
iq score and you're not moving in could
that eventually be
a possibility francis don't worry i'll
never fire you man
well i mean it could be they could be
misused but i think there's a lot of
i mean i one thing that
i mean it could also save people a lot
of time and money if they were used like
if you didn't have to go to university
and get a four-year degree just to prove
that you're
moderately intelligent and you could
just do a test
i mean that would save you four years of
your life and a whole lot of money and
then you could
get a professional job and they could
train you up in the job while paying you
like i think
i think yes there is potential for tests
to be misused but also
um it could be a really cheap way
to uh you know give people
opportunities that they otherwise
wouldn't get so i mean
i don't know i i i don't see it as being
that simple like
and and the other thing about
intelligence testing is it's
one of the only ways that smart kids
from
poor disadvantaged backgrounds uh
have been able to um
to really not intelligence tests but
having having standardized tests in
education
settings has been one of the the best
ways to enhance social mobility so
i think there's there's yeah there's
obviously
situations where the tests could be
misused and people could be treated
unethically because of it
but same goes the other way makes sense
clay
thank you very much it's been a pleasure
talking to you and as always we have
uh one final question for you which is
what is the one
thing that we're not talking about as a
society
that we really should be well
uh how great trigger pod is
that's definitely important but
increasingly people are talking about it
so what
have you have you got another one for us
well i think i think i mentioned them
earlier
i think that um uh
other rewards for jobs that aren't
economically rewarded
such as nannying and aged care work and
that kind of thing i think we should
talk about that more
and uh also
we should talk about the costs involved
in not
um acknowledging that we differ as
individuals and as groups so
the high cost of denying human nature
claire thank you so much for coming on
if people want to find you online if
they want to find coilette what do they
need to do
well uh go to colette.com that's
q-u-i-l-e-w-t-e
and you can support us uh via patreon
so call it at patreon uh we have a
podcast as well
so you can find us uh in your
podcatchers if you
look for coilette and you can subscribe
to our newsletter
so you should be able to find us a
subscription
button on our newsletter and you can
follow us on twitter
and instagram so yeah
perfect thanks for coming on the show
clay it's been absolutely fantastic
chatting with you
and if you've enjoyed the show we will
see well actually even if you haven't
enjoyed the show we'll still see you
uh tomorrow with another uh live stream
and very soon with another brilliant
episode so take care and enjoy the rest
of your day
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word